[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
good morning happy monday
from my far right gareth rhodes
chancellor malatras director of
operations kelly cummings
health commissioner dr zucker to my left
secretary governor melissa derosa to her
left budget director robert mihika today
is day 296
but who's counting i am
here are the numbers for today statewide
positivity with
without micro clusters 5.28
statewide positivity with micro clusters
5.75
micro cluster 7.1 156 000
tests 109 deaths i can't tell you the
pain
it causes to read that number
every day for 296 days
statewide hospitalizations are up 146.
there's a but uh
i say often uh these are weekend numbers
be careful about weekend numbers
the within statewide hospitalizations
there are always two numbers there's the
number of people get discharged the
number of people who get admitted
the admissions were actually down
700 admissions compared to 822
the day before uh but the discharges
are down only 472 discharges
as opposed to 728 that's because
hospitals have
a reduced staff on the weekend they tend
not to discharge as many people
so again these weekend numbers i take
with a grain of salt
i take the weekend numbers with two
grains of salt i take all these numbers
with one grain of salt smoother
direction than anything else the icus
are up 50 the intubation's up 13.
across the state percentage of that
population hospitalized finger lakes
finger lakes
finger lakes .06
they've done a reversal with
western new york western new york was a
real problem and now finger lakes
uh are a worse problem and western new
york
my formica has has flattened for the
time being and that's good news
uh finger lakes is a problem
uh because they are part of western new
york there's a lot of travel between
western new york
between buffalo erie county monroe
county etc
and you can't have two contiguous areas
where
one has a low infection rate and one has
a high infection rate because the high
infection rate winds up
infecting the lower infection rate
so the finger lakes are a problem in and
of themselves they're also a problem for
western new york
central new york 0.05 southern tier 0.03
mid hudson 0.03 mohawk valley is also a
problem
.04 north countries good capital region
0.03
long island 0.04 new york city 0.03
when you look at the positivity it's
finger lakes and it's mohawk valley
and those are the the problem areas that
we're
focusing on now this is the ongoing
covid whack-a-mole
you bring it down in one region it pops
up in another
and that's what we've been dealing with
when you look at new york city staten
island
and there is no reason for staten island
uh if you said to me manhattan
i would say well that's more dense more
people taking public transportation
more people on the sidewalks if you said
bronx queens brooklyn
for those of you not familiar with uh
new york city staten island is more of a
residential community
more single family homes than many of
the other boroughs etc so
this is just pure uh
people's behavior and people's attitude
and uh the the community's
attitude a lot of political statements
are made in staten island
uh fine and now reconcile that with the
infection rate and the number of deaths
uh kovid does not respond
to political rhetoric democratic
rhetoric
republican rhetoric you can't defy
death on political terms
statewide compared to the rest of the
nation new york is doing
very well this is a bit of a mixed
message i run into this all the time
well new york state is doing so well
compared to the nation
what are we worried about yeah i
understand
that we are doing much better than the
rest of the nation
but it's not really about the rest of
the nation
if a person dies in the state of new
york a person dies in the state of new
york
uh if a higher percentage of people die
somewhere else
that hurts our soul as americans but all
we can do is protect the people in the
state of new york
only states lower than us alaska hawaii
vermont which are obviously
great states but they are different
demographics different geography
this is very concerning this new strain
that they have found in the uk the
strain
according to boris johnson is 70
more transmittable than the old strain
they don't know if there's any higher
rate of death
they don't know if the vaccine is
as effective with the new strain
the quote from the uk
medical officer was our working
assumption
quote unquote is that the vaccine works
the strain is so serious that the uk
has closed down again if the uk
believes the strain is so serious that
boris johnson who said the week before
we're not going to cancel christmas
we're not going to close
did a 180 degree turn and then
closed parts of the uk
it's serious my friends and we are on
notice about it why
don't we act intelligently
for a change why
don't we mandate testing before people
get on the flight
or halt the flights from the uk
now many other countries have done this
this is not a case of first impression
you have many countries that have just
restricted flights from the uk
many european countries have done it
uh why are we doing nothing
120 countries require
the uk travelers to receive the negative
test
before they get on the plane in the uk
120 countries and the united
states has done nothing
people in government often believe
doing nothing is safe well if i do
nothing
i won't be criticized
uh i don't believe that i believe that's
exactly wrong
there are situations where doing nothing
is actually doing something
where doing nothing is actually an
affirmative action
when you do not require
the uk flights to be tested you
are allowing thousands of uk
passengers to arrive here every day
the authorities say they haven't found
the strain here yet
they are science-based until they find
the strain they will say there is no
strain
uh i believe intuitively
it's already here i believe that
because if it's been flying around the
world it will be here
and i say that intuitively because i
have an
educated intuition because i lived
this and you lived this
this was the spring this is how
we had that new york ambush in the first
place
this was don't worry the coronavirus is
in china
no it wasn't the coronavirus got on a
plane in china and went to europe and
came here from europe
and nobody said anything for two months
in the federal government
and it had been coming for so long that
it was then too late
if this is more transmittable than covet
70 times more says boris johnson
this is a major problem and for us
to once again be incompetent as a
federal government and take no
action is just not
is not a viable option for us
in new york we learn this lesson the
hard way
and we're not going to go through it
again
we have been victimized by federal
incompetence and federal negligence that
is a
fact and we're not going to be
victimized again
there are three airlines that come from
the uk
and fly into our airports our airports
are run by the port authority of new
york new jersey
the three airlines are british airways
delta and virgin
atlantic they daily are bringing seven
several thousand passengers per day i
am asking those airlines to add new york
state
to the list of the 120 countries
that require tests
before the flights leave the uk
for new york 120 countries do it
my request is simple please add new york
to the list of 120 countries
well you're not a country i know that
but as governor of new york state i have
asked them
to do that we do have a public health
emergency
in existence in new york state
the british airways i have spoken to
myself
and they have voluntarily agreed
to add new york to the 120
countries that will do pre-boarding
testing and they will start that
tomorrow
that's the same type of testing that
many of the countries on the 120 list
have agreed to i want to thank british
airways
uh this was a very rapid decision by
them
uh they were considerate uh and i truly
appreciate it obviously british airways
uh is could have taken a different path
but they agreed to be cooperative and
they said they will not
send flights to jfk unless
those people have been tested
pre-boarded so thank you very much
there are two other airlines delta and
virgin
and i've requested for them to
voluntarily agree
if they do not agree voluntarily then
new york state will pursue
other options but i would not be doing
my job as governor of new york
if i sat here and let the federal
incompetence
uh create another emergency
and disaster that cost the lives of new
yorkers
i am only a governor but i will do
anything i can and whatever i can to
protect the people of the state of new
york
that is my job and i
know and i believe my intuition is
correct
that this is another disaster waiting to
happen
if the uk closed down if 120 countries
require testing if canada left a plane
on the tarmac
because they wouldn't allow it to
de-board
if the other european countries have
said
that they're banning travel why are we
doing nothing
why are we doing nothing
why did we do nothing in the spring
i'm not going to allow it to happen or i
will try my best
to do everything within my power i ask
the other two airlines
to follow the lead of british airways
i ask them not to disrespect the people
of new york state
who are very gracious and are good
neighbors with the uk
but please don't abuse or disrespect
the people of new york and please don't
underestimate the people of new york
uh we protect one another i promise you
that
uh so uh please uh consider
joining voluntarily and we await your
answer
on vaccinations is my hero
nurse sandra lindsay look at that face
that needle goes in not a muscle
on her face moves that is a pro
when my time comes i hope i'm as good as
nurse sandra uh lindsay
i've had a lot of questions i want to
make something clear
politicians are now talking about who's
getting a vaccination
there is no politics in the vaccination
process
there is no politician in the state of
new york
who is in control of the vaccination
process
we went through some covet testing big
shots get to the front of the line
celebrities get to the front of the line
affluent people get to the front of the
line
this preferential treatment in covid
testing
it undermines the entire sense of
democracy
and equality and adjust
and the government that works for all
people and in
in this time of covid where we've seen
gross injustices
politics has nothing to do with it there
is no governor
there's only one governor in this state
but there's
no governor no county executive or no
mayor
who controls the process anyone
who says differently is either not
telling the truth
or violating the law so let me know if
either of those two
happen this is entirely done
by medical professionals we get the
vaccine
we distribute the vaccine to a regional
hub hospital that hospital does the
vaccinations
for that region we define
the categories of people
who are eligible phase 1a
phase 1b etc and basically we follow
federal advice on that but we tell the
hospital
this is the eligible category you
administered the vaccine
it has nothing to do with politics and
it has nothing to do
with government our only job only the
state government is involved
and our only job is to distribute the
vaccine
to the regional hub get it there and
to make sure they have the guidelines
and they're following the guidelines
we have already distributed uh more
vaccine
uh and our hospitals have vaccinated
more
people than any state in the nation
uh we did this despite the snowstorm
that we had over the past few days
which made it actually uh a little more
interesting
and a little more difficult but uh
welcome to 2020.
38 000 new yorkers have already received
the vaccine dose
this is where the vaccines went there is
no politics in this allocation
this is all proportionate to
the number of people eligible in that
class uh so if we're talking about
essential healthcare workers
this is where they are by percentage new
york city
hospitals get more yes because
new york city has a larger population
long island hospital got more
yes because there are a larger
percentage of the population
and so forth and so on but that's the
only differential in the allocations
new york state so far is the number one
state
and i want to thank our hospitals who
are doing a great job and i want to
thank our state department of health
and ogs who's actually distributing it
to the hospitals
more vaccines are coming every day 346
000 modern
coming this week 120 000 more pfizer
doses coming this week
we expect to have a total of 630 000
doses by this week
this week we increase the priority
populations
that the hospitals will be allowed
to administer federally qualified health
center workers emts coroners medical
examiners funeral home workers
other congregate care workers and
residents
this week we also start to the federal
program to vaccinate
nursing homes residents and staff
residents and staff
in nursing homes it is estimated that it
will take
six weeks three days at each facility
day one everybody receives one shot
that should take two weeks day two uh
second shot day three the remaining
staff so three days
they basically uh break up the residents
and staff
in three groups and they do it over
three days total program is supposed to
be
six weeks the pharmacies
we have worked with the pharmacies and
the federal government cvs is going to
do 271
walgreens 253 other pharmacies 94.
these are the 618
nursing homes that are enrolled in the
program
again it is basically proportionate to
where the nursing homes
are this morning we started in the
nursing homes
and these are pictures from this morning
uh there we are in the bronx in
rochester
in queens
everyone receiving the vaccine
ppe on the nurses
and doctors
key for me in this vaccination program
is to make sure the vulnerable
communities and underserved communities
are not left behind
they were left behind during covet
highest death rate highest infection
rate
lowest testing rate black communities
latino communities poor communities
left to the markets forces
you will see once again uh black
latino and poor communities left behind
we're doing everything we can to make
sure that doesn't happen and i want this
state to be a model
for the nation of equitable outreach
when it comes to a vaccine
we have a task force that we're putting
together
the co-chairs of the task force are
rosanna rosado our great secretary of
state
leticia james our attorney general
not pointing a finger at anyone in
particular there this happens to be the
picture
mark morial former mayor uh
who i worked with for many years he's a
great fellow pat wang president ceo of
health first so i want to thank them for
their
service this is the full task force
and their job is to come up with an
operational logistical plan how do we
get it into black churches how do we get
into
public housing authorities how do we get
it into community centers
how do we run a public education
campaign
to the black community in the latino
community in the poor community saying
this is safe
there are very real resistance
uh a very real resistance to taking this
vaccine especially in the black
community there's a history that
would give one a right to be skeptical
we need a public education to combat
that
we're also putting together vaccination
kits that can be sent
throughout the state that are fully
contained
to do vaccinations for a community we
call them community vaccination kits
but in one shipping container
it can be everything that that
uh bring it to a public housing
authority to a church
to a community center anywhere in the
state
everything you need computers i.t
medicines wall dividers tables
chairs schematic for how you set up the
space
uh space could be about ten thousand
square feet
because people have to come in they have
to be greeted they have to be registered
the vaccination itself takes about 15
minutes
the medical personnel then like the
person to remain
in that area in that space
for about an additional 20 minutes half
an hour
just to make sure there's no response
but
in this one community kit all that
will be present
we'll have these ready to then work with
community groups churches housing
authorities
so we can just send it to those places
again
uh my goal is this state has
should do a better job than any other
state
uh rural communities poor communities
black and latino communities public
housing other health care
deserts in general
what we're doing is what most states are
doing we're just a little bit ahead of
it
the it's a foot race between increasing
vaccines and slowing the spread
that's all this is and we're coming
well we're in the midst of the holiday
season and
spread the number one spread
overwhelmingly
is small gatherings living room spread
75
of the spread is coming from that area
everything else is relatively de minimis
and we're in the heat of the holiday
season right
i said before thanksgiving you think
about it as thanksgiving
i don't think about it as thanksgiving i
think you think about it as day one
of 37 days of
holidays which is a totally different
socialization pattern from any other
time
of the year and the socialization
pattern
is what determines the spread of
do you think i should clip something in
the back
or you think it looks okay